Did I notice a little,
like, spark
between you
and Miss Cheri?
-You saw that, too?
-Yeah.
I totally felt something.
I think there was something
between you two.
When we go back in
to give the verdict,
see if you can get some --
like, try to wink at her.
I can't. I am physically
incapable of winking.
Try winking.
I have to...
[ Laughs ]
I could shut them both
and then open one.
[ Water bubbling ]
A clear bong really makes
getting high look like science.
[ Coughs ]
I mean, did you see
how mad the daughter was
at the mother
for just going out
and taking out that loan?
Yeah, payday loans
should just be
for, like,
a ransom situation.
That's the only time you should
ever go to a payday loan place.
What did you write down
in there?
What are your notes?
This says "Costco," and I just
underlined it a couple times.
[ Laughs ]
'Cause I like Costco,
and I could go
to Costco right now.
So that's your solution
to their problem
is just you'll
drive her to Costco?
I could take Miss Cheri
to Costco occasionally.
Get some Chocolates
of the World.
Jug of salted caramel.
I'm assuming she has
a Costco card.
Try winking.
See if maybe, like,
in the moment, you can wink.
Oh, you think because --
Try winking at her
when we get in there.
Just 'cause I want to see you
double blink at her.
-Is it "winked" or "wunk"?
-When?
When you -- Past tense.
Like, if I were to wink.
-"Wunk" is never a word.
-"Wunk"?
-"Wunk" is never --
-So it's "winked."
Also, when would you
ever tell a story
where you winked in the past?
Let me tell you a story
where someone winked at me.
Yeah, okay.
I was at the Oscars,
hanging around outside
the Oscars after it was over.
Yeah, yeah.
Burt Lancaster winks at me.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Burt Lancaster?
Yeah.
Straight up winked at me.
-Really?
-Yeah, he went like this.
Yeah?
[ Laughs ]
Just, like...
He sounds cool.
It was the best wink
I ever got.
I wonder if Burt Lancaster
has ever told this story.
Never.